hello Stanford community I'm Rob Siegel
I'm Alisa décimo my name is ed Batista
I'm marine McNichols Ashley Martin here
my name is Donna Troy I'm Christian
wheeler hello my name is Becky luster
I'm rod I'm Zak normal oh hi folks this
is Sara singer oh we are here for my
house on Stanford campus you can see
it's incredibly quiet we miss you all
welcome to my home office I mean my
Stanford virtual teaching studio Milo is
going to be a part of the classes this
is my home assistant mr. Bongo Josie my
trusted coated retriever please very
happy to have me around we know these
are really uncertain times I feel more
connected to those who especially living
in different parts of the world I know
it's been difficult we canceled plans to
the new anxieties to the inability to be
around people at times like these I try
to focus on things in life that I'm
grateful these are certainly going to be
trying times for all of us we can all
use a little extra tending right now one
major silver lining for me and this
period has been that I'm getting to
spend a lot more time with the family
what it makes me realize is that those
Stanford is here Stanford is actually
where you all are it's online at the
moment then amazed at how people have
bonded together it's been an opportunity
to take a step back this quarter would
be what we make it it's really been
pretty miraculous the way people have
come together to make it all happen
you appreciate each other because at the
end of the day we are all on this
together and I have no doubt that we are
going to come out stronger and more
unified than ever before
in these times I think about how we can
make the best out of the situation well
we welcome you back we know these are
not times that you would normally script
for a spring quarter of the 2020
academic year so let's do our best
thank you for all you are and will be
doing I can't wait to see you online
this work more work I can't wait to see
you a person in the future
I certainly hope we see each other up
close and in person soon
[Music]
you
[Music]